Sukces naszego algorytmu VQE w dużej mierze
zależy od stanu i circuit,
od których zaczynamy.
Jestem Victoria Lipinska i w tym filmie
omówimy dostępne nam opcje
przy ich projektowaniu.
Przyjrzyjmy się bliżej
wszystkim elementom
w każdym przebiegu kwantowej
części VQE.
Zaczynamy od stanu referencyjnego,
niekiedy zwanego stanem początkowym.
Przepuszczamy stan referencyjny
przez sparametryzowany circuit zwany
formą wariacyjną
z wstępnym doborem parametrów,
a następnie mierzymy stan
w bazie Hamiltonianu
po przepuszczeniu go przez circuit,
by uzyskać wartość oczekiwaną. Teraz
przejdziemy przez każdy z tych elementów,
zaczynając od stanu referencyjnego.
Typowym wyborem stanu referencyjnego
jest stan zero.
To znaczy stan, w którym komputer kwantowy
jest już zainicjalizowany.
W problemach kwantowej chemii
można też używać tak zwanego
stanu Hartree-Focka,
który jest wynikiem metody
Hartree-Focka.
W skrócie, teoria Hartree-Focka
daje prosty sposób budowy
stanu referencyjnego przez przybliżenie
stanu podstawowego układu kwantowego.
Szuka obrotu
w przestrzeni stanów,
który minimalizuje energię stanu podstawowego.
Wreszcie stan referencyjny
może być bardzo specyficzny dla problemu
i możesz chcieć wybrać
stan niestandardowy.
Gdy wiesz, jakie właściwości ma twój układ –
na przykład symetrie
lub konkretną liczbę elektronów
w stanie – możesz to wykorzystać,
żeby mieć lepszą zbieżność algorytmu
VQE.
Wybór dobrego stanu referencyjnego
jest ważny dla zbieżności.
Stany referencyjne bliskie
stanowi podstawowemu
mogą sprawić, że problem osiągnie
zbieżność znacznie łatwiej i szybciej.
Równie ważny
jest dobór wstępnych wartości parametrów,
które podajemy do formy wariacyjnej.
W zależności od stanu referencyjnego
i parametrów początkowych
możemy osiągnąć zbieżność szybko, wolno
lub wcale.
Przyjrzyjmy się temu wykresowi
i dla celów wizualizacji
wyobraźmy sobie, że nasza przestrzeń parametrów
ma tylko jeden parametr.
Bardzo dobry stan referencyjny
pozwala zacząć bardzo blisko
końcowego stanu podstawowego,
a wtedy zbieżność jest szybka.
Z drugiej strony, jeśli zaczniesz bardzo daleko
od stanu podstawowego,
stan referencyjny a,
będziesz musiał pokonać wysoką barierę energetyczną,
co prowadzi do bardzo wolnej zbieżności
lub jej braku.
Omówimy to dokładniej
w module klasycznej optymalizacji
na tym kursie.
Przyjrzyjmy się teraz sparametryzowanemu circuit
działającemu na stan referencyjny, czyli
formie wariacyjnej.
Gdy ten circuit – U(theta) – działa na stan referencyjny,
produkuje to, co nazywamy stanem próbnym,
psi(theta) lub niekiedy ansatz.
To właśnie ten ansatz jest
mierzony w odpowiedniej bazie,
żeby uzyskać wartość oczekiwaną
energii.
Omawiane tu formy wariacyjne
WEBVTT
są motywowane chemią.
Pamiętaj jednak,
że istnieją też takie zainspirowane
kwantowym uczeniem maszynowym
i innymi algorytmami
bliskiego terminu, takimi jak kwantowe
przybliżone algorytmy optymalizacji.
Omówmy
kilka popularnych wyborów ansatzu w chemii.
Unitarny sprzężony klaster, czyli UCC,
to metoda pierwotnie zaproponowana
w pierwszej publikacji o VQE
i jest powszechnie stosowana
w problemach kwantowej chemii.
Zazwyczaj,
gdy parametryzujemy stan kwantowy,
pracujemy z wykładniczo
wieloma parametrami.
Jednak żeby uczynić circuits przygotowawcze efektywnymi,
potrzebujemy wielomianowej liczby operacji,
a więc wielomianowej liczby
parametrów.
UCC to przykład sposobu przygotowania
stanu próbnego z takim circuit,
wywodzącego się z metody sprzężonych klastrów,
będącej złotym standardem
w kwantowej chemii.
Najpopularniejszy wybór to unitarny
sprzężony klaster
jedno- i dwupobudzeniowy,
czyli UCCSD w skrócie.
Ponieważ UCCSD jest motywowany specyficzną
konfiguracją elektronową problemu,
musimy zapewnić stan referencyjny,
który właściwie odzwierciedla układ.
To jest stan Hartree-Focka.
Ansatz UCCSD zwykle daje
dobre przybliżenie stanu podstawowego,
bo uwzględnia jedno- i dwu-elektronowe wzbudzenia
w danej cząsteczce.
Liczba parametrów w UCCSD skaluje się
kwadratowo z liczbą spinowych
orbitali.
UCCSD można bardzo dobrze
dostosować do problemu,
ale niestety skalowanie kwadratowe
nadal prowadzi do bardzo głębokich circuits,
które są trudne dla obecnych
komputerów kwantowych.
Dlatego badacze z IBM zaproponowali
bardziej heurystyczne podejście,
gdzie można dostosować formę wariacyjną
do sprzętu
co daje efektywnie
wykonywalny circuit.
To znaczy, że stany próbne są parametryzowane
przez quantum gates
i są adaptowane
do dostępnego urządzenia fizycznego.
To bardzo heurystyczne podejście,
przyjazne sprzętowo.
Na podstawie tych przykładów przyjrzyjmy się
spektrum możliwości
wyrażania naszej
formy wariacyjnej.
Wiele z nich
jest już zaimplementowanych w Qiskit,
więc zachęcam cię do samodzielnego wypróbowania,
która z nich jest najbardziej odpowiednia
dla problemu, który próbujesz rozwiązać.
Patrząc na wykres, z jednej strony mamy bardzo heurystyczne
formy wariacyjne.
Gdy specyficzność problemu jest niska, ale
są zaprojektowane do implementacji
na prawdziwym sprzęcie.
Są też wysoce ekspresyjne,
w tym sensie,
że można nimi wyrazić
wiele stanów kwantowych.
Jednak problem, który może pojawić się na późniejszym
etapie klasycznej optymalizacji,
to napotkanie
tak zwanego barren plateau,
który omówimy w następnym module.
Z drugiej strony
mamy wysoce specyficzny dla problemu unitarny
sprzężony klaster, który świetnie sprawdza się
w klasycznej chemii, ale
WEBVTT
jest trudny do implementacji na sprzęcie kwantowym
ze względu na duże głębokości circuit.
Generalnie obliczenia mogą być bardziej udane, jeśli możesz
przede wszystkim wybrać stan referencyjny i wstępny zestaw parametrów,
które tworzą ansatz bliski
stanowi podstawowemu.
I po drugie, unikaj zbędnych parametrów.
Wprowadzają one albo
większą głębokość circuit bez korzyści,
albo tworzą większą przestrzeń parametrów,
co prowadzi do plateau
w klasycznej optymalizacji.
To, które parametry są konieczne, to pytanie
specyficzne dla problemu,
wymagające starannego przemyślenia.
Porozmawiajmy teraz o tym, gdzie nasz honorowy gość,
Hamiltonian, ukrywa się w tym wszystkim.
Jak nauczyliśmy się w poprzedniej sekcji,
Hamiltonian po mapowaniu na qubity
jest reprezentowany jako suma
ważonych ciągów operatorów Pauliego.
Ostatecznie jednak
chcemy wyliczyć wartość oczekiwaną
naszego Hamiltonianu na ansatz
produkowanym przez formę wariacyjną.
Na szczęście mechanika kwantowa
jest miła i liniowa,
i właśnie tego użyjemy,
by uzyskać wartość oczekiwaną.
Oto jak to działa.
Wiemy, że Hamiltonian jest ważoną
sumą Paulich.
Z powodu liniowości
wartość oczekiwana sumy
jest równa sumie wartości oczekiwanych
każdego ciągu Pauliego.
To świetne, bo jak już wiesz,
pomiar w bazie Pauliego
to po prostu obrót
standardowej bazy pomiarowej.
Zamiast mierzyć wartość oczekiwaną
na tym ogromnym Hamiltonianie
reprezentowanym jako suma, najpierw wyliczamy wartości oczekiwane
poszczególnych składników,
a na końcu sumujemy
z odpowiednimi wagami.
Dlatego w wielu zasobach
widać tylko jednobitowe obroty
po ansatzu.
To właśnie implementuje Hamiltonian
przy każdym uruchomieniu circuit.
W następnym filmie
omówimy, co się dzieje
podczas kroku klasycznej optymalizacji.
Do zobaczenia.